TAIWAN, SO IS SHE SERIOUS ABOUT
BIPARTISANSHIP?
JOINING ME NOW, MIKE POMPEO,
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
ESTHER SECRETARY, HAVE YOU HEARD
FROM THE SPEAKER SINCE YOU MADE
YOUR OFFER?
>> THANK FOR HAVING ME ON.
I HAVE NOT HEARD FROM HER.
IT WAS A LITTLE BIT
TONGUE-IN-CHEEK IN THAT I PREFER
TO TRAVEL WITH LOTS OF OTHER
PEOPLE, BUT HAVING SAID THIS,
THIS IS ABOUT AMERICA.
IF THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE NOW
ALLOWS SOME SECOND RATE FOREIGN
DIPLOMAT SAYING WE MIGHT DO
SOMETHING REALLY HOT IN AMERICA,
THE THIRD HIGHEST-RANKING
FEDERAL OFFICIAL SAYS YOU CAN'T
COME HERE.
WE ACQUIESCED TO THAT THREAT, WE
ARE IN FOR A LONG DECADE HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
PRESIDENT BIDEN NEEDS TO GET
SERIOUS, DEFEND THE THINGS THAT
MATTER TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FROM CALIFORNIA TO NEW YORK, TO
FOR TO COME TO WASHINGTON, TO
ALLOW THE CHINESE TO JUST ISSUE
A STATEMENT AND CHANGE THE
DIRECTION, CHANGE THE ACTIONS
THAT THE UNITED STATES WILL
TAKE, BECAUSE WE ARE FEARFUL OF
THEM.
WE ARE IN FOR A LONG STRUGGLE,
AND IT WILL NOT END WELL WITH
THAT KIND OF FAILED LEADERSHIP.
>> Laura: SO WHAT MESSAGE DOES
IT SEND IF WE ALLOW CHINA TO
DICTATE THE TRAVEL OF THE WOMAN
WHO IS THIRD IN LINE FOR THE
PRESIDENCY?
WHAT MESSAGE DOES THAT SEND TO
THEM?
>> IT TELLS EVERYONE OF OUR
ALLIES IN THE REGION, THE
JAPANESE, SOUTH KOREANS, THE
OSTERMAN'S, IT SAYS DON'T HANG
WITH THE AMERICANS, THEY ARE
FEARFUL, AND IT TELLS OUR
ADVERSARIES, YOU MENTIONED
AFGHANISTAN, CERTAINLY THE SAME
THING HAPPENED IN UKRAINE AS
WELL.
WE SAID A MINOR WOULD BE OKAY.
WHEN YOU'RE NOT STRONG -- THIS
IS A TOUGH, NASTY WORLD OUT
THERE.
WHAT IS THE GREATEST THREAT TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TODAY, THE
CHINESE, HIS PARTY, DEMONSTRATE
WEAKNESS, THEY ARE GOING TO WALK
THROUGH THE FIRE AND THEY ARE
GOING TO MAKE LIFE REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR US.
IT DOESN'T NEED TO BE THAT WAY.
WE ARE THE MOST POWERFUL NATION
IN THE WORLD, WE HAVE AN ECONOMY
THAT IS UNRIVALED.
WE CAN BEAT THEM, WE CAN WIN
THIS, WE CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE
ANOTHER 250 GOODYEAR'S FOR
AMERICA BUT SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
WAS GOING TO TRAVEL TO A
SOVEREIGN NATION, THE NATION OF
TAIWAN AND CHINA SAID WE DON'T
THINK SHE SHOULD GO, YOU GO
OKAY, NEVER MIND, WHERE IN A
QUICKER CENTER, THAT'S A BAD AND
DANGEROUS PLACE TO FIND YOURSELF
BURIED
>> Laura: IT IS SO
UNBELIEVABLE I CAN EVEN BELIEVE
WE ARE HAVING TO TALK ABOUT IT,
BUT SPEAKING ABOUT WASHED UP
PENTAGON TALKING HEADS, HERE'S
RETIRED ARMY GENERAL BARRY
McCAFFREY.
WATCH.
>> MOST PEOPLE SAY YOU SHOULDN'T
GO.
IT'S A THOUGHTLESS MEASURE AT
THIS POINT TO HAVE A POLITICIAN
THERE.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT POSITIVE CAN
COME OUT OF IT AND THERE WILL BE
SOME SIGNAL, SOME MEASURE BY THE
CHINESE IN RESPONSE IF PELOSI
VISITS.
NOT A GOOD IDEA.
>> Laura: MR. SECRETARY, IS
EVERYBODY BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY
CHINA?
EVERYONE?
I'M NOT SAYING HE IS BUT HE
CERTAINLY SOUNDS LIKE HE IS.
>> BOY, NOT EVERYONE, BUT TOO
MANY.
WHETHER IT'S HOLLYWOOD WHO
ACQUIESCES THE SAME WAY BIDEN
DID -- THEY DON'T PUT CHINESE
CHARACTERS WHERE THEY CONTINUED
TO BUY STUFF WHERE THEY ARE
COMMITTING ATROCITIES, EVEN TO
MAKE OUR BIGGEST CORPORATIONS IN
AMERICA.
THERE ARE A LOT OF FOLKS DEEPLY
CONNECTED TO CHINA IN A WAY
THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE
UNITED STATES.
THE GENERAL THEY'RE KIND OF JUST
ASSUMED FAILURE, HE ASSUMES THE
CHINESE OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
DICTATE WHO CAN TRAVEL WHERE
FROM THE UNITED STATES.
WHAT'S NEXT?
ARE YOU GOING TO TELL LEADERS
THEY CAN'T TRAVEL SOME PLACE
ELSE BECAUSE THE CHINESE DON'T
LIKE IT IF THEY GO TO FIJI OR
THE SOLOMON ISLANDS OR WHEREVER
IT MAY BE?
THIS IS A VERY DANGEROUS PATH TO
HEAD DOWN.
WE OUGHT TO DO THE THINGS THAT
MATTER AMERICA, THE THINGS THAT
DEFEND AND PROTECT OUR
SOVEREIGNTY IN OUR SECURITY.
WE CAN DO THAT.
WE NEED NOT BE FEARFUL, WE NEED
TO BE STRONG AND CLEAR.
WHETHER SPEAKER PELOSI WENT OR
NOT SIX MONTHS AGO MIGHT NOT
HAVE MEANT -- BUT ONCE SHE SAID
SHE WAS GOING, DO NOT GO IN THE
FACE OF A CHINESE THREAT
DEMONSTRATES REAL WEAKNESS AND
REAL DANGER FOLLOWS.
>> Laura: I JUST KEEP SAYING
THE PENTAGON TOLD US THAT THE
AFGHAN ARMY COULD HOLD THEIR
LINE, FOR WHAT, SIX MONTHS A
YEAR?
THEY COLLAPSED IN ONE WEEK.
SO UNTIL WE DO A RETROSPECTIVE
ON EVERYTHING THEY'VE GOTTEN
WRONG, I'M SORRY, LEADERSHIP --
I'M NOT TALK ABOUT THE
RANK-AND-FILE.
I MEAN, WE ELECTED A PRESIDENT
TO BE OUR COMMANDER IN